you're very cool after this interview
I'm gonna call home oh my god well
you're a magnificent pagan Beast thanks
what's the message I'm getting a tan off
your camera lights she became known as
[Applause]
isn't it nice to get away there were two
hundred seventy five episodes eleven
seasons and 28 Emmy wins et was right
there from the beginning in fact we were
neighbors Cheers was filmed next door to
where we shot et Diane and Sam are
having a relationship and it's very hot
very hot you disgust me
I hate are you as turned on as I am or
what you might not know about the series
Cheers was dead last in the ratings when
it debuted cliff and norm drank mere
beer at the bar and Modern Family's Ed
O'Neill actually auditioned for Ted's
role of Sam Malone could you not discuss
my private life with everyone that comes
in what would you like me to tell him I
don't care she's a hooker
Shelley left after five seasons telling
us she wanted to spend more time with
her husband and two-year-old
it was truly I think one of the hardest
decisions of my life not just of my
career but of my life but I wanted more
time with that little girl and with that
big guy that helped me make that little
girl how do you do get over here she's
supposed to be with
she was Rebecca
unsere Kirsty's first day on the set
well I thought it would be awkward for
everybody so I dressed like Shelley
there have been a lot of ridiculous
unbelievable rumors about my sexual
prowess I just want to tell you that
most of them right on the money for the
series finale et flew to Boston as
thousands of fans packed the streets for
the end everybody held their emotions in
check until the director yelled cut a
little bit of joy a little bit of relief
out came eleven years I don't know what
[Music]